Autopsie du rap jeu ?
Ils tuent le rap à coup de « moi je »
Les valeurs de notre art sont pillées par les neu-jeu,
J’ai la rage, rappelle-toi de nous à leur âge
Nos textes foudroyaient, électriques comme l’orage
Mais sache que le hip hop renaîtra de ses cendres
On ne laissera pas une bande de petits cons le descendre,
qui parlent de fesses et de thune de janvier à décembre,
ils tirent complètement à côté pendant que nous on fait des centres
Hey arrête un peu de dire que le rap c'était mieux avant gros,
tu sais ce qui était mieux avant
c'était avant que tu dises que le rap c'était mieux avant,
gros
On mène la vida loca,
tourne en Y au tiékar.
Tu mènes la vie que je veux pas,
dire faites pas ci faites pas ça
Ton rap on dirait des messages de prévention de l'état,
Sèche pas les cours, mets ta ceinture, porte un bonnet s’il fait froid
Qu'est-ce que je m'en tape de tes conseils moi j'ai déjà un papa
Ton flow est chiant en t'écoutant je me suis endormi 3 fois
Moi je veux plein de billets,
Louer des grosses villas, pleins de gadjis dedans toi t'es fatigué
(oh grosse folle)
T'aimes pas les euros, tu payes encore en francs, t'écoutes Franky Vincent
La vérité vous méritez pas de compter comme nos héritiers,
Nous irriter, c'est ce que vous faites avec ce manque de sincérité,
Sincérité, ça c'est l'idée,
Rappin' rappin' everyday
Je coupe, et découpe, coup de coude en toute sincérité
Ton flow me tacle, tape les tympans telle une matraque,
pas de tacte, Jacques a dit a dit j'acte ma contre-attaque,
Tak! Tak! C'est le bruit de mon arme, énorme est mon âme et ramène nous man,
Époque des bonhommes comme Vador et Saroumane...
Yeah
Ça sert à rien
de dire des mots
Moi je fais du bif bif bif bif bif
En disant rien,
Du genre,
Ahlala ahlala oh
Ah ah ah
Heeey oh
Hm hm hm hm hm
Zey zezezey
zazay zezezeye
Regarde ce qu'ils ont fait du rap qu'on leur a laissé
Ils l'ont piétiné,
Complètement massacré,
Un art de la rue qui termine dans une chicha
Parle de chatte, de shit, de fesses et de four
Sont en hess' d'amour,
Font les durs font les forts mais je les baise sans effort
Babylone dans le décor, Nabuchodonosor,
Et combien d'entre eux ont vraiment connu la rue?
Dans le prince de Bel Air, je suis Will, ils sont Hilary.
Je suis Will, ils sont Hilary
Quand tu rappes, tu nous les casses, casses, casses, nigga
Et en boîte jamais tu passes, passes, passes nigga
ta mère ce soir je la capte, capte, capte, nigga
je lui démolis bien sa chatte, chatte, chatte, nigga
Gros tu,
Arrête de répéter qu'on est faux, tu
Kifferais baiser les meufs dans mes clips qui bougent leurs gros culs
Sauf que vu que t'as 60 balais bah tu bandes plus,
J'ai vendu, tellement de CDs que mon argent je le compte plus
Et ça fait clique clique, ta mère dans un clic-clac
Je l'emmène en pique-nique, ma bite c'est un big mac !
Mais Dimitri, ça va pas ?
Maman ?
Ça va pas d'insulter les mamans des gens comme ça ?
Non mais, c'est, c'est la musique ça, faut...
Musique ou pas musique mais...
Je m'en fiche !
Les mamans ça se respecte !
Là, on se la ferme là, quand il y a sa mère !
On t'entend plus hein !
Looser, va !
Romuald !
Maman ?
Tu trouves ça drôle d'insulter les gens qui respectent leur mère ?!
Non, c'est pas ça, c'est juste qu'en fait...
Romuald, tu te tais.
Respecter les mères, c'est très important.
Ouais, c'est vrai.
Je sais pas ce qui m'a pris,c'est...
Dis comme ça...
C'est peut-être le truc d'ailleurs...
Sur lequel on est tous d'accord !
Ouais, c'est vrai...
Respecter les mamans c'est...
C'est important.
Une maman on en a qu'une
Et pour elle, je pourrais
Décrocher la lune
Faut la respecter, si elle t'envoie chercher, du pain bah nan faut pas rouspéter...